the 1990s brought a tidal wave of
sitcoms crashing onto the shores of TV
some were amazing
others were terrible but all of them
eventually came to an end
keep watching to discover the most
interesting stories of 90s sitcom
cancellation news radio was one of the
most acclaimed sitcoms of the decade but
all of its positive critical notice came
in spite of or perhaps because of
battles with its network creator Paul
Simms fought with NBC over everything
from scheduling to plot lines by his
telling NBC wanted more established
stars they Foley Andy Dick and Joe Rogan
were all well known in the world of
comedy but they weren't exactly
household names throughout America in
1997 Simms who was almost certain that
his show was getting canceled gave a
profanity-laced
interview to Rolling Stone he admonished
NBC for not giving news radio a slot on
Thursday night's must-see TV lineup and
he called out executives by name
afterwards the show was briefly
cancelled before being brought back
which led to everyone awkwardly walking
back what they said and playing nice the
dynamic of the show changed
significantly in season five following
the death of Phil Hartman he was
something of a big brother to the rest
of the cast and addressing his death
resulted in an uncomfortable tonal shift
Hartman's old SNL castmate Jon Lovitz
was added to the news radio cast but he
never quite clicked it also didn't help
that Preston Beckman NBC's head of
scheduling at the time despised the show
during news radios run it changed time
slots 11 times amidst all this turmoil
it was canceled after the fifth season
sports night Aaron Sorkin's dramedy
about the behind the scenes of a
SportsCenter type show was never a rated
success but it almost didn't matter
it was critically acclaimed it won
awards and the viewers who did watch it
were a passionate Bunch when fans got a
sense that sports night wasn't long for
this world they set up websites
petitioning to save it when ABC axed the
show several other networks including
USA HBO and Showtime expressed interest
in picking it up negotiations with
Showtime went furthest with Sorkin
claiming that they offered him about 37
million dollars for two more seasons
that much money on a network where
ratings weren't critically important was
an almost perfect scenario but alas
Sorkin had no choice but to turn it down
that was because during sports nights
second season he
created a little show called the west
wing for NBC he did almost all of the
writing for both shows splitting his
days between the two of them also around
this time his wife was pregnant and he
realized he couldn't give his all to
sports night anymore
Showtime didn't want to enter into a
heavy commitment without Sorkin going
all-in
so negotiations ended home-improvement
was without a doubt one of the most
popular sitcoms of the 90s it spent its
entire eighth season run rated in the
top ten in the series finale aired on a
third of all TVs in America but there
was never a 9th season because stars Tim
Allen and patricia richardson both
wanted to move on richardson was offered
30 million dollars for another year but
she turned it down because she decided
to focus on her family she was a single
mother to three children and
home-improvement was keeping her away
from them too much Allen meanwhile was
at the most bankable point in his career
during his run on home improvement he
starred in major box-office hits like
the Santa Claus Toy Story and jungle 2
jungle Hollywood was calling and besides
no matter how much he was offered he
didn't want to do the show without
Richardson Wow I just shows how smart
you are long before she played a
neurobiologist on The Big Bang Theory
Mayim Bialik was an average teenage girl
on the family sitcom blossom the show
had a dedicated audience before it ended
after five seasons it was canceled for
three main reasons the stars were
getting older the audience was aging out
and it had tough competition in the form
of Melrose Place the thing about shows
focused on teenagers is that they always
grow up eventually the final episode of
blossom sees the title character getting
ready for college and a life utterly
unlike the one fans fell in love with
the primary audience for these shows
tends to be tween girls and their tastes
change in mature as they grow up so
shows like blossom tend to have a shelf
life especially when more mature
programs like Melrose Place around
blossom for its part did tackle some
touchy subjects that became part of the
show's DNA this kept it relevant but it
couldn't save it entirely kids learn
some important lessons from blossom
about topics like divorce and addiction
but then they grew past it dinosaurs was
a strange show there's no other way to
put it in many ways it was a normal
sitcom about a suburban family dealing
with everyday issues except for the fact
that every cast member was a dinosaur
puppet the show nevertheless somehow had
some of the sharpest writing on TV of
its era and it was without question one
of the most visually interesting shows
of the decade alas the cost of dinosaurs
sophisticated puppetry ultimately made
it unsustainable
especially when ratings started to dip
rumours spread that it was the most
expensive half-hour on television
eventually it just wasn't worth what it
cost to make and so ABC cancelled it but
the writers weren't interested in going
gently into the good night as they
decided to make one of the most bonkers
series finales in TV history entitled
changing nature the episode sees the
dinosaurs try to handle an invasive
plant species by accidentally setting
off an ice age that leads to the
extinction of the entire species the
script prompted a call from ABC's
president asking the writers where they
got the hutzpah to kill off the entire
cast the writers responded that they
were inspired by the planets actual
history in the words of series creator
Michael Jacobs when you do a show about
dinosaurs you always have that
extinction card in your pocket and we
wanted to use it Ellen made television
history in 1997 with the puppy episode
in which the main character played by
Ellen DeGeneres comes out of the closet
Susan I'm gay
while this has endured is a landmark
moment in TV history it also proves to
be the beginning of the end for the show
as a combination of backlash and weird
creative decisions cost ratings too
plummets during Ellen's fourth season
DeGeneres and ABC were fighting about
the show's content network executives
were reluctant to let Ellen come out and
they started putting content warnings
before episodes DeGeneres objected to
this and threatened to walk before
making a fifth season Media discussion
about the show after the puppy episode
aired was growing more and more complex
Chaz Bono at the time the media director
of GLAAD worried that the show was
leaning in a little too much as he put
it it's one thing to have a gay lead
character but it's another when every
episode deals with pretty specific gay
issues ultimately Ellen was cancelled
after five seasons though it's legacy
lives on to this day grace under fire
was an early project for Chuck Lorre who
would go on to create such series as Two
and a Half Men and the Big Bang Theory
like many of his future shows it was a
raiding success the title character a
divorced mother and recovering alcoholic
who's played by Brett Butler the show
soared on the wings of her talent and
eventually struggled as her real-life
problems intruded on to the set the
departure of two cast members and five
executive producers were all attributed
to Butler's erratic behavior and drug
addiction during a crossover event
production teams from other shows were
especially horrified the crew for The
Drew Carey Show even got t-shirts that
said I survived Brett grace under fire
productions was halted on at least two
occasions for Butler to attend rehab
both times resulted in long delays both
added to her bad reputation and both
contributed to a ratings decline
eventually ABC got fed up and pulled the
plug Butler is now clean and sober and
has expressed remorse for how she
behaved at the time salute your shorts
was one of Nickelodeon's first big
live-action success stories following a
group of kids at a summer camp it paved
the way for the success of future
sitcoms aimed at kids in the following
decades two seasons were produced
successfully on a shoestring budget but
then production changes forced the
cancellation in June 1990 Nickelodeon
studios opened in Orlando Florida
going forward the network intended to
have all of its programming
there salute your shorts have been
recorded in Los Angeles up to that point
and it struggled to adapt to the change
in location the cast was primarily
children and teenagers who all decided
that it wasn't worth it to move across
the country Hey Dude one of Nick's other
live action comedies face the same
predicaments ultimately with nobody
moving both shows were canceled The
Nanny was so popular in the 90s that
anyone who watched back then can still
hear Fran Drescher's laugh right now
from sense-memory
despite lasting six seasons the show's
cancellation came as something of a
shock
years later Drescher attributed it to
her character Fran fine finally acting
on a romantic tension with Max Sheffield
will they won't they storylines permeate
many long-running sitcoms and their
culmination always changes the dynamic
of a show with the tension gone viewers
theoretically have less of a reason to
tune in and writers then have to come up
with new storylines Drescher initially
had no interest in having Fran pair up
with Max but she was forced into the
decision after the network threatened
cancellation as she put it in 2017 when
a show is built around a love that can't
happen you have to keep it that way she
may have just been right about that as
ratings plummeted after the wedding and
the show was off the air a season later
Veronica's closet was never a critical
darling but that didn't matter at least
for a while when a show on NBC is
produced by the same team that made
friends it automatically has some sway
instead of good reviews Veronica's
closet got something better a 9:30 p.m.
Thursday night timeslot on NBC
this was smack dab in the middle of the
must-see TV lineup right between
Seinfeld and ER during its first season
and between Frasier and ER during its
second ratings were great during this
time until they started to taper off
towards the end of season two bad
critical notice also caught up to it and
audiences were growing less and less
interested NBC responded to this ratings
dip by transferring Veronica's closet to
Monday evenings alongside suddenly Susan
some observers saw this as a way to dump
shows that were underperforming NBC had
openly promised critics and fans that
the show would improve and they even
brought on new writers from friends to
help it out ultimately none of this
tinkering mattered as the monday
timeslot killed it without a loyal
following Veronica's closet cratered in
the ratings on its way
getting cancelled suddenly Susan had a
lot going for it it had the support of a
major network a solid cast headlined by
Brooke Shields and one of the best time
slots on TV season one aired on Thursday
nights at 9:30 p.m.
right between Seinfeld and ER when it
was moved to Mondays the ratings took a
steep drop though they were still decent
but around the end of the third season
suddenly Susan was facing many
challenges cast member David Strickland
took his own life which was a major blow
to the rest of the cast and crew
furthermore during the off season almost
the entire creative team left as did
actor Judd Nelson he was replaced in the
final season by Eric Idle but it wasn't
enough between an unfamiliar creative
team in an unfavorable time slot
suddenly Susan dropped in the ratings
like a stone and it was canceled
midseason the remaining episodes were
burned off in the summer check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]